-It's so great to see you.
-It is so good to see you.
-You look fantastic as always.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for coming
back to the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-It feels like you were just
kind of on.
-Yes. It does feel like
I was just here.
-Right?
-Yeah.
But I was like "Come back."
And you were like,
"Alright, I will."
And I go, "Come back
for like three days."
And you go, "I will."
-I will, and I'm here.
-And you did it. Yes, exactly.
I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a "Tonight Show" takeover.
New album on Friday, "Holy F,"
congrats.
-Thank you.
-I know, I can't say the word.
But that's what it is.
-Yes.
-But we'll get into all
that stuff.
Tomorrow we're doing
the monologue together.
We're hosting together.
-I know.
-Are you nervous?
-Yes, of course I'm nervous!
-No, you're not.
-Yes, I am!
-Have you ever hosted anything?
-I hosted the Teen Choice Awards
one time, years ago.
-And that was not --
-It was fine.
It's just I'm -- I feel at home
when I'm singing on stage.
Not when I'm talking.
-Right.
So when you --
But you'll do a song,
you'll tell stories or stuff.
Won't you?
-Kind of. I mean, not --
I'll talk to the audience
a little bit.
But like I don't --
I don't know.
See, now I'm getting nervous!
[ Laughter ]
-No, I don't want you
to be nervous.
But this is -- Have you ever
tried stand-up at all?
Ever thought about that?
-Hell no!
Did you see how
I just freaked out?
I don't want people not laughing
at my jokes.
That would be mortifying.
-No, I get --
You get used to it, trust me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
That's going to be tomorrow.
I'm very excited about that.
I'm happy that you're here.
It's a big deal.
This is a big week for you
because the album comes out
on Friday.
-Yes.
-And also, your birthday --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Saturday.
-Saturday.
-Yes.
-Pal, it's a big week.
-It is.
And it's my 30th birthday.
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-Ooh!
Trying to remember my 30th.
30 is a good year.
-Yeah, I'm excited about it.
-30 was good for me.
47 is where I'm at now.
-Uh-huh.
-Bingo.
[ Laughter ]
That's the best age so far,
yeah.
47.
-Nice.
-I finally am starting to figure
things out.
-Nice.
-This hair piece, everything.
[ Laughter ]
-How to open a Capri Sun.
-Yeah, how to open a Capri Sun.
It's very difficult.
Well, I want to talk
about the tour
because you're about to do
this giant tour.
I mean, it's massive.
And over the weekend,
you played a couple gigs.
-Yes.
-Now, that's just to kind of
like -- It's almost like going
to clubs and working out.
You're just like, "I want to get
the rust off."
Or you're like, "Can I do it?"
What are you thinking when
you're doing those gigs?
-Well, this was my first show
in four years.
-Wow.
-So, I'm hadn't toured --
I mean, I hadn't performed like
a full show in four years.
And I'm about to go on tour,
the Holy [bleep] tour.
-Yeah, exactly yeah.
-And it was kind of like --
I did have nerves.
I was like,
"Can I still do this?"
Like, "I need to get the rust
off for sure
'cause I'm about
to hit the road."
But like, it just was -- it was
really actually nerve-racking.
-And how did it feel
when it was done?
-It felt so good.
-You could still do it.
-I can still do it.
-I knew you could.
-Just like riding a bike.
-Yeah, what do people --
What should they expect
from this show?
Or don't expect anything?
-Well, you can expect
live music.
See, that's why
I'm not a comedian.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's good.
That's funny.
-Thanks.
-I do.
-No, my music is more rock now.
So I'm not doing,
like, even my old --
My older songs kind of have like
a rock flair to them.
They're not like pop anymore.
-Were you always
rock-influenced?
-I was in my teen years,
and so I feel like I'm just
going back to my roots now.
And, like, my first album,
my first and second album,
they had more rock influences,
and yeah, here we are.
-I heard -- I did a radio
interview from a radio station
in Fort Worth, I want to say,
and they were saying,
"Oh, Demi came in as a kid
and like just performed --
'Oh, would you sing something?'
and just rocked it out."
-Aww.
-And you destroyed.
Do you -- When you were a kid,
when you're performing,
I mean, you've been playing
your whole life.
Do you just go and --
You go wherever --
How do you end up
going on stage?
Who gets you on there and how do
you get the confidence
to go like, "I can do it"?
-Well, you know, I don't know.
I kind of -- My first time
on stage was when I was five.
And I sang in the school talent
show in kindergarten.
-Do you remember what you sang?
-"My Heart Will Go On"
by Celine Dion.
And you know, like, that was
a very challenging song,
and I just kind of went for it.
-And who's rooting you on on the
sidelines? Is it your family?
-My mom, yeah, my family.
-That's wild.
-That's pretty much
who got me on stage.
-"Oh, Demi's gonna be doing
stadiums."
It's so great to see you start
there and then
now you're just
the biggest star. I don't know.
And then, of course, yeah,
stand-up, we'll work on.
-Okay, yes, we'll work on it.
-We'll work on your stand-up.
But I know you like to do cover
songs from time to time...
-Yes.
-...in your shows.
You just did Goo Goo Dolls?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why Goo Goo Dolls?
-Well, that song "Iris"
by the Goo Goo Dolls
is one of my favorite songs
ever.
-Is that --
♪ I don't want to ♪
-Yes.
-Right?
-♪ I don't want the world ♪
Is it "save me"? "See me"?
-"See me." Yes.
-Oh, sorry, I said "save me."
♪ I don't the world to see me ♪
-Just like that.
-Yeah, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Because I know another Goo Goo
Dolls too. They're great.
And you just picked that one,
that's one of your jams?
You crushed it.
-Yeah, it's one of my jams.
-I want to show a clip
because this is
you performing this
over the weekend. Look at this.
-♪ I just want you
to know who I am ♪
♪ I just want you
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's just a cover?
That's you just going,
"Oh, let's do a song.
Let's just try that one."
-Yeah.
-Is that going to be on the set?
Or we don't know?
-It is. It's in the set.
-Yeah!
-It is.
-I love that.
-So you have to come see.
-Definitely. I cannot wait.
You know, a friend of ours,
Kelly Clarkson,
just did a cover of you.
-Yes, she did.
-And I asked you about this
and you were like it was kind of
a big deal because that was one
of your original --
-Influences, for sure.
Her voice to me, I remember
watching her on "American Idol"
and just becoming so inspired by
her that my e-mail address
when I was young was
littlekelly@yahoo.com.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-And so for her to like cover
my song years later
was just a full-circle moment
'cause I also used to
cover her songs when I was
younger as well.
-Really?
-Yeah, definitely.
-I wonder if we can find video
of that.
Watch it. We did.
Here's video of 13-year-old
Demi Lovato singing
"The Trouble With Love Is."
Take a look at this.
-♪ The trouble with love is ♪
♪ It doesn't care
how fast you fall ♪
♪ And you can't refuse
that call ♪
♪ See you've got no say at all ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Thank you.
-You got the gift. Alright.
Before you go, I know you're
performing for us tonight,
which I appreciate,
thank you so much.
I figured we have to do this.
I mean, it is --
-Oh, my God, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-This is my painting
I did of you --
-Yes!
-Years ago.
So I figured we'll do this here.
I'm getting frosting everywhere.
-Thank you.
Aww, thank you, guys.
-♪ To you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear Demi ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Make a wish.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, that's what
I'm talking about!
Happy birthday.
Congrats on the album!
Demi Lovato, everybody!
Demi and I are doing something
fun after the break!
Stick around, come on back.